nous sommes à chaumont-sur-tharonne pour
la cinquième édition de la biennale de
sologne
on retrouve en direct sur place flavien
texier bonsoir flavien vous nous
promettez une surprise dans le journal
de midi tout à l'heure oui attendait
rebecca je suis là je suis là je suis en
train d'admirer en fait cette sculpture
monumentale et puis d'ajuster ma
pochette et oui parce que ce soir vous
l'aurez compris on a sorti la tenue de
soirée car vous l'avez dit nous sommes à
la 5e biennale de sologne à
chaumont-sur-tharonne en direct ici
depuis le parc de la mode
rassurez-vous des surprises il va y en
avoir on va parler de tout ça avec notre
invité est celle qui nous accompagne
depuis la mi-journée il s'agit de
micheline bornito mieux bonsoir madame
au soir merci d'être avec nous ici
depuis le parc de la mode
j'ai envie de demander ça sert à quoi au
fond une biennale alors la 5e biennale
de sologne est un devenu un rendez vous
incontournable pour les amateurs d'art
éclairé d'art contemporain de sculptures
en paysage mais également pour le grand
public parce que nous voulons des mots 4
et démocratiser cet art et leur apporter
des oeuvres sur un plateau dans un
environnement magnifique comme le
château de la mouette en extérieur et on
appelle ça l'art paysage c'est ça non la
paix ça plutôt l'art monumental va l'art
monumental en paysage car les ce genre
de d'oeuvre gigantesque magistral ne
peuvent pas être confiné dans un endroit
fermé et si elles s'épanouissent
surtout quand on a la chance d'avoir dix
hectares de terrain pour mettre en scène
120 sculptures et c'est bien ça l'art se
confond je le disais avec avec ses
paysages du parc de la meute
combien de combien artistes sont
présents cette année micheline environ
58 artiste qui expose 120 sculpture
monumentale mais qui expose aussi des
plus petites havre qui sont destinés à
la vente parce qu'il faut que l'art se
vendent également
il faut que les artistes puissent vivre
de leur art des artistes micheline on en
a rencontré beaucoup vous
et bien tout au long de l'après midi on
en a choisi deux deux artistes trois
oeuvres
les images sont signés etienne braye
leçon c'est toujours philippe roy et
puis le montage et bien ce soir c'est
armelle garraud qui s'y colle
re garder une sculpture en bronze
c'est l'oeuvre de jean marc un artiste
originaire de normandie avant d'être
bronze sa sculpture était en bois un
arbre croisé un jour par hasard peut
promener dans la campagne
et puis je suis tombé sur cet arbre
incroyable c'est une émotion vraiment
très belle je suis c'est incroyable
cette merveille de la nature avec
l'emplacement des deux troncs une sorte
d'intimité avec comme des bouche qui qui
sombra ce qu'ils chuchotent
et puis une autre forme comme ça un peu
d'oreille qui a tourné vers l'extérieur
un peu plus loin un autre bronze qui
évoque celui là la maternité
c'est une pièce organique avec j'avais
repéré un petit rouge et a grandi j'ai
placé comme un oeuf
ça fait un peu comme un ventre ici
j'appelle la pièce une maternité
végétale à la maternité végétales parce
qu'elles portent quelque chose en
devenir la vie jean paul moscovino lui
est originaire du loiret il travaille
l'aluminium et met en scène l'anatomie
des femmes t'as ici peut-être une jambe
là tu as un dollar que tu vas avoir eu
un bras là tu vas avoir une autre jambes
etc
et c'est cette géométrie de l'anatomie
d'une femme assise qui devient abstraite
et encore même suggéré une tête là haut
pour créer une une
un volume qui va être habitable comme
une architecture autour des sculptures
un dialogue s'engage cette dame apprécie
beaucoup le l'ouverture vers le ciel en
fête ce que ça donne un côté aérien à
une oeuvre qui paraît qui est fait en
métal et donc je trouve que c'est un
équilibre entre à la fois la matière et
ce côté aérien de l'oeuvre artistique
des oeuvres qui nous interpellent des
oeuvres exposées jusqu'au 17 septembre
retour ici en direct depuis le parc de
la motte à chaumont-sur-tharonne on va
vous montrer tout de suite une autre
image à micheline je crois que vous avez
envie de nous commenter cette oeuvre
cette oeuvre de michel audiard tout à
fait c'est une et diane chasseresse qui
dit sologne dit chasse et la présence de
diane chasseresse était indispensable
michel audiard s'est inspiré de ou dont
le célèbre sculpteur pour cette diane
mais il voulait la rajeunir rénover la
moderniser et il a eu une commande
d'assez de quelqu'un qui s'intéressait
beaucoup à ses hommes absolument et ça
lui a donné l'occasion à deux sur cette
oeuvre
et il faut admirer le côté matières peau
qui qui lui travaille utilise du carton
ondulé syrie il faut à l'obtenir il faut
venir la voir
effectivement c'est magnifique merci
beaucoup micheline c'est tellement bien
la 5e biennale de sologne que france 3
centre val de loire reviendra mardi 5
septembre ce sera la matinale avec
héloïse bruzat dès 9h50 et puis nous
rebecca on se retrouve demain on va
aller un peu plus loin à la marolle en
sologne vous savez pour faire quoi
la fête tout simplement pas très bien
bonne soirée d'ici là flavien à demain